yes if you follow me on Twitter you knew
that I was out camping this entire
weekend so I got back and I haven't
ironed by button up seeing on my regular
attire so it's still laundry day so you
get me a t-shirt today it's casual
Jeremy days so I figured let's talk
about the Paranormal Activity 4 trailer
so you know me I've been a fan of the
Paranormal Activity movies I thought the
first one even though it was you know
boring it can be seen as boring for some
people I loved it I thought it did its
job really well as the series is going
on I've liked them less and less still
ultimately enjoyed them this one I can't
help but see he's just a cash grab one
of the first things you see is the star
of the whole movie he's this really cute
teenage girl and she is cute like not in
a creepy way it was probably kind of a
creepy way every heterosexual adult male
that saw that trailer was like she's way
too young for me to think she's cute
that being said she's cute let's just
all be honest with ourselves would be
creepy together it's just the fact you
see her sleeping in her bed then things
start happening she starts getting
creeped out so when this teenage girl
gets freaked out I'm gonna be like of
course she's freaked out she's a teenage
girl that's what I'm I think in the
entire movie I'm like yeah she's
overreacting whatever you know why
because teenage girls probably overreact
if the studio was looking for a
character to bring validity to this
entire concept they probably looked in
the wrong place and of course I want to
make the chicks more attractive it
brings in more of an audience but I like
the sincerity of having average people
in movies like this except I found this
picture of the chick from the first one
and yeah that's not bad I mean you take
the first Paranormal Activity movie what
are they in their mid to late 20s
they're adults and they got freaked out
that makes the audience cause or
adults they pay their taxes they
probably vote but probably not you know
what's going on in the world and this
ghost is freaking them out which makes
me freaked out and the fact that they
got this teenage girl now makes me think
they're trying to pander to a teenage
audience which means everything that I
loved about the first one's not gonna be
in this movie he's gonna have jump
scares it's just gonna be a basic
teenage horror movie and that's beside
the fact that wasn't it's supposed to
end at the third one why are they making
a fourth one I felt like the third one
wrapped up everything with the family
now they're making a fourth one how's
she gonna tie in why does a ghost even
give a about her sorry not ghost a
demon it's been a demon the motion
lights have been turning on and off
every night Yeah right that shit's gonna
be that weird kids from across the
street watch
yeah yeah so you got a couple of creepy
people that moved in next door it's
probably the chick with the kid you know
the in their little demon they're all
hanging out another demon what has he
gotten bored he's like now I'm gonna
with the neighbors you people are
now boring me alright I'm gonna cheat on
you with them that's why I like on the
rare occasion when a director or
producers like no we're stopping the
story now cuz it needs to stop now cuz
that's where the story should stop like
Christopher Nolan's Batman movie you
know the studio was like can you please
just make like nine of them he was like
no I'm making a trilogy because that's
my story I respected ood for sticking to
his guns like that it makes the entire
package just more enjoyable they start
bleedin franchises like this until they
die it just makes me think I saw I feel
like this is more of a rant in a trailer
review so let's just show more of the
trailer
when the team is doing this thing you
know you see the camera freaking out and
pausing which I thought was actually
YouTube when I was watching the trailer
it's not us in the movie however this
detract from the effect is when you
paused the video you can have a cut
there where you add something you know
it's like oh the deme is not there in
the video glitches and then the demons
there yeah they can do that in editing
when you have a glitch you can have a
splice you have a splice you can just
easily add things it's much more
effective in a movie like this to have
what they did in Paranormal Activity one
we just have a steady shot and half
things happen in the scene you're like
was that just started happening it's
almost like it felt real which is the
intended effect of paranormal activity
concept I feel like this one's gonna be
the weakest one of the series this is
all I'm saying
normal wait what was that show that
again is that paranormal activity in the
two Deathly Hallows where's the third
one
where's the wine I think we found the
premise alright teenage girl getting
haunted by a demon find the Elder Wand
I'm pretty sure you can fight this thing
off fully it was so easy in real life to
get rid of your creepy ass neighbors so
in the end I like the first three we're
now getting a fourth one I feel like now
the Paranormal Activity movies are a
good idea that spawned I saw the trilogy
and is now gonna be blood dry with a
fourth one then a fifth one probably a
sixth one and in the death of a
franchise nonetheless I hope it has
creepy ass moments that creep the
out of me - any jump scares don't do
that I've enjoyed the paranormal
activities thus far so hey let's see
what the fourth one has so the
Paranormal Activity 4 trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it
comment below let me know and as always
if you'd like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more